[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we got married mom what are you two
gonna do about money I don't know Mom
make it no one's ever gotten married
before were the first people to do it
I'm a married man don't touch me like
I've always wanted to make TV well then
you came to the wrong place art that's
what we make here I'm excited I'm
excited for you I got the job
the game show I set my stuff to they
just hired me as a writer Wow
we got drinks tonight it's Thursday
tradition you should come
I didn't think you're gonna show what do
you want what do you like I like to have
my own show something you you will
complain I can't I gotta work
you remind me of me when I was your age
I always wanted so much but then when I
got what I wanted I was always too
afraid to take it
[Music]
what is you there guy
yeah I feel like sometimes everything is
just hard
what do you want I don't want to fight
the first year of marriages the heart is
you know like that old saying the first
year should be you best
[Music]
wife wife wife
you